welcome back this is the bench bureau
show so joe biden's poll numbers are
starting to look not so
great these days according to gallup his
approval rating has now dropped to 50
that is a six point dump since the
beginning of june he was at 56
in june which was very high he is now
down to 50
he's got 45 disapproval he is likely to
sink
probably a little bit further before all
is said and done
and there are a couple of factors here
the the first factor is that
look he is not an articulate human being
at this point he's obviously losing it
the fact that he's obviously losing it
really had no impact so long as people
were in a good mood about which way the
country was going
but it is very disquieting when the
country appears to be sort of stagnating
and at the same time the president of
the united states can't speak english
anymore there's a clip going around
online of
joe biden saying something no one seems
to be able to discern what exactly he is
saying here there are some theories
including
my butt's been wiped was the big theory
on twitter i'm
not going to attest one way or another
all i can say is that like you laurel
and yanni you hear what you want to hear
here is the president of the united
states saying something incoherent
it must be what what must be what what
must be what
yeah i don't know i don't know what he's
saying there i got nothing
got nothing he could i mean not
implausible the only question is whether
it is ron clayne who is doing it
or whether it's the establishment media
at this point but
again none of that would matter if the
country felt positive about the
direction in which we are moving the
country does not feel that way
according to abc news a majority of the
public now say they are pessimistic
about the direction of the country that
is a market change from the roughly
one-third 36 percent that said the same
in a poll published may 2nd so in
essentially
two months we've dropped from 64 of
americans saying they are positive about
the direction of the country
to only 45 saying that they are positive
about the direction of the country
in that early may survey americans were
more optimistic than pessimistic by a 28
percentage point margin
optimism is now underwater by 10 points
looking ahead to the next 12 months
fewer than half
45 now report feeling optimistic about
the way things are going that is a
significant drop from about two-thirds
in the may poll and that has happened
among every subgroup
optimism is down about 20 points among
democrats and republicans it is down 26
points
among independents among democrats about
say they are optimistic about the
direction of the country over the course
of the next
12 months there are a bunch of issues
that are playing in here
the biggest issue obviously is this
rapid uptick in the number of coveted
cases now
part of the problem for the biden
administration is that they set the goal
post wrong
and because they set the goal post wrong
everybody's kind of freaking out when
they shouldn't be freaking out the goal
post should be
can you get a vaccine if the answer is
yes we're done
that's the end we've reached the end go
back to work you get it you get it if
you don't you don't
be smart get the vaccine but if you
don't want to your problem right then we
would be done
and people would be optimistic they'd be
like okay yeah it's still out there but
i'm vaccinated and
and so i'm okay or i'm unvaccinated but
i chose not to get vaccinated so it
really is like my problem at this point
instead because the biden administration
set very early on
zero covert as the goal right the
pandemic being over didn't mean
that it would still be moving through
the community and hitting people who are
unvaccinated it meant there would be no
covet
because that was the goal now whenever
you get these headlines about
unvaccinated people getting covered
people freak out
yes and unvaccinated people and measles
mumps and rubella unvaccinated people
get polio
it turns out that vaccinations are
effective at preventing the
transmissibility and or
the serious symptomatic presentation of
diseases
this is a thing that we have known for a
very long time in public health
but if you set the goals wrong then you
got a problem and the reason that the
biden administration set this goal
is because if they had set the goal as
when do we get to open up life again
then they would have had to actually
have an honest debate about whether
andrew cuomo or ron desantis was doing
things right at the height of the
pandemic
didn't want to have that debate they
simply wanted to say that lockdowns
were in fact in and of themselves a
public good
they didn't want to have the debate and
so they set themselves unrealistic
standards and now they got some troubles
on their hands whereas i guarantee you
that in countries that basically said
yeah we're probably going to have to
learn to live with this thing like in
florida rhonda stands his numbers pretty
stagnant
he's been saying for a while you're
going to have to make your own decisions
your individuals
live your life and now the vaccine's
available i honestly don't know tons of
people in florida
who are spending a lot of time agonizing
over this stuff
because you can go to any publix and get
the vaccine right now
you can and you have two choices in
american society you can get the vaccine
or you can get covet and there is no
third choice
the delta variance is just too
transmissible
but there is this this widespread belief
and paranoia that
it's exacerbated by the media of course
because the media has to make it seem
as though risks to the unvaccinated are
risks to everyone which is not true
so every time you see a breakthrough
case they're like wow delta's going to
break through and wreck the vaccines
lock down time
that is the only way that you can
convince vaccinated people they ought to
start masking up again
or that you can convince people that
their kids ought to be masking is by
suggesting
that doom is right around the corner
even if you're vaccinated so
the biden administration is having some
real problems at this point according to
the daily wire a new poll indicates
1.8 million americans have turned down
job offers in order
to stay on unemployment insurance which
uh it turns out when you pay people to
stay home
they're like hey sounds great morning
consult surveyed 463 out of work
american adults at the end of june
13 roughly 1 in 8 said they had refused
job offers while unemployed because they
had quote received enough money from
unemployment insurance without having to
work
others said that child care obligations
worries over cover 19
and a lack of job flexibility limited
their willingness to take new positions
because 14.1 million adults were
collecting benefits at the time of the
survey
morning consults calculated that roughly
1.8 million americans turned down jobs
due to the handouts
under president biden's 1.9 trillion
american rescue plan the federal
government funded 300
per week enhanced unemployment insurance
a policy that has caused sluggish labor
market recovery 26 states
all but one of which are led by
republicans have therefore opted out
of the program also
nine of the ten states with the most
robust labor market recoveries have
republican governors
nine out of ten meanwhile all of the
bottom ten are run by democrats
that is not a shock there's an entire
report on npr talking about the
differences between unemployment rate in
massachusetts and new hampshire which
were very close in terms of unemployment
rate before the pandemic
now massachusetts has like twice the
unemployment rate of new hampshire why
well because new hampshire turned down
the unemployment benefits and said no
we're we're just not going to do that
we're not going to do that
it turns out that the democratic
policies are a giant fail
they are not succeeding and this means
that democrats
have to they must condemn all of their
political opposition as evil because if
it comes down to who's got more
effective policies they have a real
problem on their hands